we rely on Rudy you may know us as food
beast GQ sent us around the country to
find the coolest bars and restaurants
you happen to be in LA sfera facts
district there's five of the coolest
places to check out first we went to
terrine and met our bartender buddy Ryan
you made us a killer drink to kick off
the night and then we're off to the
races next we hit up Blue Bottle coffee
for a quick pick-me-up
Ryan's fancy that dude only pays 100
about six Benz of guys safe in Los
Angeles yeah we get it
gas is expensive in LA so that's why
we're walking Ryan took us to this new
rooftop bar called EPL P for a Taiwanese
Bubba cocktail usually don't like boba
cuz that kind of crazy
buh-buh-buh plugged in super good we
were tired of walking so we hopped in an
uber and headed to the time for a quick
drink at an LA staple we decided to
check out supreme but it was closed so
we grabbed a slice of pizza we noticed a
bunch of kids waiting in line outside of
the supreme store for some crazy
exclusive hat so we got them some pizza
too they were nice I hope they get their
hats after our random act of pizza
kindness we decided to have a nightcap
with Ryan at the kibitz room
the legendary LA bar where Guns and
Roses officially formed no Axl but it
was a lot of fun we said goodbye to Ryan
he's gonna be missed
lucky for us Anders is connected to the
kibitz room this is us eating one of the
most famous pastrami sandwiches in LA
the milkshakes were crazy look at milk
moustache
oh this is a guide in Fairfax you can't
go wrong if you think we're way off
send us your favorite spots